[Music]
[Applause]
richard roper is a
great movie critic chicago sun times
friend of the show and on short notice
has joined us to review in bruges's and
is it an all-time great movie richard
thank you for joining us how would you
sum up in bruges
well the first thing i would do is say
it's in
rouge that's part of the problem that's
in bruise
and also would point out that um colin
farrell is a brilliant actor actually
and he's going to be continuing to play
uh the penguin in the
the batman sequel now in bruges is from
martin mcdonough who did it was his
first film he's a great playwright
writer director he did three billboards
a few years ago which won a bunch of
oscars i love the film dan it's a movie
within a movie it's got a lot of
tarantino tarantino-esque stuff
great performances a lot of dark comedy
but it's one of those films that also
has a unique look to it because we have
not seen a lot of movies filmed in
bruges
why
why you know as a you know a very smart
man
why can i not really put my arms around
in bruges
[Music]
i think one of the problems is you might
not recognize that it's based in large
part on some of the works of harold
pinter so if you went back and
studied that it would give you some
context and but i you know listen
seriously it is
listen it's not the deepest movie of all
time it does have a lot of themes about
you know redemption and loyalty and a
lot of really dark comedy which i think
is really difficult to pull off what i
think this film does and in addition to
colin farrell you've got two brilliant
actors in brendan gleason and ray finds
brendan gleason plays the guy who
becomes kind of like uh you know he's
the mentor to the colin farrell hitman
he's a veteran hit man who actually
starts to be protective of this guy and
then
ray finds is great playing their boss
you know the most evil guy in the world
maybe maybe i'll give it another shot
maybe i'll i just don't have time to sit
there and watch
it's football season richard
uh maybe in april
i'll go i'll watch you this after march
madness all right uh our all-time
favorite movie and then if you can
comment on this uh fritzy yeah i'm sure
you'll be shocked rocky is uh the one
that comes to mind for me
rocky
any issue with rocky
rocky's a brilliant film when you go
back and look at it realizes this it has
this independent film look to it it's
actually better it's become kind of a
cliche because of all the rocky movies
that followed it when you watched that
first one the acting the screenplay by
stallone brilliant
uh fritzy and you're not joining us via
zoom but fritzy looks like paulie
bert young
just not
all right uh seton your favorite movie
of all time uh well it's not the deepest
movie ever um
but it's the first movie that popped
into my head so it must be my favorite
movie animal house
oh okay
i told you wait i thought you loved the
movie of
the fashion uh devil horse prada devil
wears prada okay
okay are they both
great movies
well animal house is a classic devil
worst product is actually really really
well done but it's you know i put it in
my top 10 000 of all time
okay
uh marv your favorite movie of all time
he got game
okay
richard
one of the best uh
athletes and as an actor performances of
all time with ray allen as jesus
shuttlesworth and he got game i love
that film i think it was uh it i put it
in top 10 basketball films of all time
[Laughter]
that was snarky there marv just there's
a shot though
i loved he got game and and you no you
just said
you said one of the top 10 basketball
movies of all time
wow yeah it's not better than you got a
lot of shot i got a lot of genres
genre uh paulie what's your
richard in a stunning display of banned
parenting my parents let me see the
movie jaws at age seven
that said i still is it has the impact
it had then i think jaws is an all-timer
i completely agree i actually did a
screening in chicago for its 40th
anniversary and my only uh requirement
was people young people who had never
seen it before because i wanted to watch
it with people who had never seen it and
it was great to sit in the back of the
theater and see these millennials and
gen zers
really digging it and getting scared and
you know all the great moments in there
so i love that pic
i don't have a favorite movie of all
time richard
do you well you know i get that dan
cause when people ask me that you know
the obvious answer is the godfather but
it's like it's sort of like picking a
favorite song right i mean it depends on
the mood you're in sometimes if you're
in a mood for a great comedy or serious
drama i've been really revisiting once
upon a time in hollywood recently
tarantino's film from a few years ago
because it's one of those films that has
that repeatability factor where you find
and discover new cool things every time
you watch it
yeah
i mentioned to these guys
that they're movies that you it doesn't
matter where it is when it's on like the
bourne movies i don't care where it is
i've seen them all i will watch
born movies with matt damon i don't like
the one with jeremy renner
i'll watch that hoosiers comes on i will
watch that no matter where it is there's
certain movies no matter where it is
it doesn't matter i'll watch
i think the generational one example of
that is shawshank redemption which was
not a huge hit when it came out but then
tbs played it on and then almost like on
an endless loop and if i click across
shawshank i don't care where we're at in
the movie 27 minutes to go four minutes
ago it would be sacrilege to click away
paulie can you see if shawshank
redemption is on right now i already did
it's on red's about to get released from
prison okay oh geez oh geez
oh boy
good stuff hey uh richard thanks for
joining us uh as always we appreciate it
have a great weekend
all right dan take care guys that's
richard roe for chicago sun times movie
critic